I'm Boris Johnson's cabinets arrive for
their morning meeting Westminster was
awash with the news that Downing Street
had decided to play hardball with the
European Union
probably they hadn't even been briefed
on the suggestion that the UK looked
like readying itself to collapse the
talks on a compromise deal but that does
appear to be the suggestion faced with
the delaying disruptive and denying
tactics of the opposition we say on
behalf of the 17 point four million
enough enough enough we need to leave
Downing Street then briefed that the
German Chancellor had demanded that the
economy of Northern Ireland stay in the
EU Saudis but in the last nail in the
coffin but the EU insisted the talks
were not yet dead technical talks are
continuing today so I don't see how
talks could have actually been broken
down if they are happening today and in
the days to continue there is no denying
the loss of faith though the President
of the European Council Donald Tusk
tweeted this Boris Johnson what's at
stake is not winning some stupid blame
game at stake is the future of Europe in
the UK as well as the security and
interests of our people you don't want
to deal you don't want an extension you
don't want to revoke Quo Vadis which is
Latin for where are you going with
Parliament suspended from Wednesday
opposition parties now assume Johnson
will call an election next week after
accepting a brexit extension as demanded
by Parliament's and then campaigning to
leave the EU with no deal by getting
them to then offer the extension cuts on
the 17th of October or the 18th of
October when the European Council meets
he would then be able to say to
Parliament and to Jeremy Corbyn in
particular I've got the extension I want
my general election now and I think in
those circumstances Jeremy called when
we highly likely to say yes the blame
game between London and Brussels mirrors
the entire brexit debates there's
precious little left except bad blood
certainly the European Union never
really thought that Boris Johnson
administration was actually interested
in a deal because his proposed
compromise over what happens in Northern
Ireland is soaked
located and convoluted the EU thinks it
was basically set up to fail it is
assume though that if Boris Johnson asks
them for an extension to breakfast they
will grant it if only as a last chance
hope that a different government might
be elected in the national election
which could save the UK and the EU from
a No Deal brexit Lawrence Lee al Jazeera
in London